- [Voiceover] Graph
0.04 on the number line.
So here we have this number line
that goes from zero to 0.1, or 1/10,
and between zero and 1/10,
we have one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, ten equal spaces.
So each of these spaces
represents 1/10th of the distance,
is one out of ten equal spaces.
Or we could say, it is
1/10th of this tenth,
it's a tenth of the way to 1/10th.
That's a little bit tricky,
maybe let's pause and
look at that visually
and think about what does a
tenth of a tenth really mean.
So here I have already drawn
a picture that's divided
into 10 equal pieces.
And if we shade one of them,
then we're shading 1/10th.
This right here is 1/10th.
And this amount right here is
what the number line showed,
the whole number line showed 1/10th.
But then we had divided that
tenth into 10 equal pieces,
so if we split that 10
into 10 equal pieces,
we're gonna have something like this.
So here again this top row would
represent the entire tenth,
from the whole number line,
but each little piece would
be 1/10th of that whole tenth.
Or, so this is what each little piece
on the number line represents,
or we could say that's 1/100th,
a tenth of a tenth is a 1/100th,
'cause when you divide
10 into 10 equal pieces,
you're gonna end up with 100 pieces.
So a tenth of a tenth is a 1/100th.
So looking back at the number line,
now we know that this distance,
a tenth of our tenth, is 1/100th.
And we want to graph 0.04.
Well this four right here,
let's think about place value.
The zero's in the ones,
the next zero in the tenth,
and this four is in the hundreds,
so we could call this four hundredths,
or even the fraction, 4/100.
So if one of these lengths is 1/100
and we wanna go 4/100,
then we're gonna need to
go four of these lengths.
One, two, three, four of these lengths
would be four of the hundredths, or 0.04.